You remember in the Lion King,
you may not remember when,
when,
when Mufasa,
that's the king,
right?
Goes and takes Simba up to show him his
territory.
He says he is the King of everything the
light touches.
And that's a very old idea and you guys
had no problem with,
you know,
that was fine,
that made sense and that I will be on
the light was the darkness.
And that was the elephant graveyard.
That was death.
That was the place of death and danger.
That's where the hyenas hung out and you
weren't supposed to go there.
And so of course,
Simba,
because he's a rule breaking hero,
just like Harry Potter immediately goes
there.
And so you know,
that's like the forbidden fruit.
It's the same sort of idea.
If you want someone to do something,
the best thing to do is tell them that
they shouldn't and not explain why,
you know.
So for example,
if I said to you at the beginning of
this class,
look,
I've got one rule here,
don't sit in that chair no matter what
you'd be thinking the whole year,
especially if I reminded you just what's
up with that chair.
Like that's chairs magical.
All of a sudden you,
some of you might even,
while you probably wouldn't,
because this is a ridiculous example,
but maybe you know,
you come to class early and sit in that
chair just to see what would happen.
You know,
and people are very curious and that's
exactly what we're like.
And that's a very old story too,
right?
It's like opening Pandora's box.
Don't open that box.
You'll be sorry.
It's like,
oh,
you know,
all of the horrors of the world fly out.
Believe me,
you will open Pandora's box many times
in your life because you know,
with your family or maybe your mate or
maybe your children,
you'll have this idea that they have a
box with things in it that you want to
know about.
And you'll say,
well,
I'm kind of curious about this
particular event,
so why don't you tell me about it?
And they say,
well no,
we probably really shouldn't open that
box and you keep bugging him and then
they open it and then all sorts of
things fly out that you didn't expect
and then maybe you think,
hey,
it would have been better if I would
have just left that damn box closed,
but,
and you can do the same thing to
yourself,
believe me.
And so the Pandora's box idea,
the forbidden fruit idea,
that's,
that's a major league idea.
And part of the reason in the Judeo
Christian tradition,
why people are saddled with the notion
of original sin is because hyper
cortically developed chimpanzees without
much sense.
Can't keep their hands off things.
And so they keep exploring even when
they know better and every time they do
that,
they learned something that is,
that destroys the paradise that they
currently inhabit.
Right?
Because there's plenty.
You and I never learned anything in your
life that's of importance without it
having a pretty damn destabilizing
effect on you at the moment of
realization,
right?
You learn something happy.
It's like whatever.
You know that all that means is that I
was doing things right,
like it's nice and everything,
but it's not informative.
You do something and all hell breaks
loose.
That'll make you think.
Now it's for sure.
You might never stop thinking for the
rest of your life.